on this wednesday night the first covet
19 vaccine approved for use on canadian
children
age 12 and up and marks a significant
milestone in canada's fight against the
pandemic
canada reports two new deaths linked to
the astrazeneca shot
alberta's latest pandemic protocols the
community can't get gas because of your
guys both
rules rising backlash to the
restrictions and will they be enforced
the declining mental health of canadians
it needs to be talked about
a lot more than it already is plus
incoming
and out of control the space junk
hurtling
towards earth
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
canada has become the first country in
the world to approve the use of a
covid19 vaccine
in children as young as 12. and
provinces are already making plans
to administer it health canada has
reviewed data from clinical trials of
the pfizer biontech vaccine
and deemed it is safe and effective for
12 to 15 year olds
phase 3 clinical trials were done in the
u.s more than 2 200 kids age 12 to 15
were enrolled
over 1 000 received the pfizer biontech
vaccine and the other half received a
placebo
18 in the placebo group got covid19
no one in the group that got the vaccine
became infected
and the only side effects were temporary
and mild
almost immediately some provinces have
announced they will make kids 12 and
older eligible for the pfizer biotech
vaccine
as soon as monday but with limited
supply right now they'll have to get in
line behind the adults
eric sorensen has our top story tonight
on kids
vaccines and the timeline to get them
protected
the timing couldn't be better as canada
prepares to receive more than 8 million
pfizer vaccine doses this month the
canadian government
has become the first to approve pfizer
shots for the youngest age group so far
12 to 15 year olds health canada applied
its science and evidence-based review
process
required that the same high standards
were met while younger people are less
likely to experience serious cases of
coping 19
having access to a safe and effective
vaccine will
help control the diseases spread to
their families and friends
i have no hesitation about getting the
vaccine for my children
stacy carroll has two teenage daughters
doing school online
and believes vaccinating them will help
return life to normal
sooner even though many children are not
getting severely ill
i don't want to take that risk with my
kids and
by having them protected they're
protecting themselves and they're
protecting other people in the community
some provincial governments already plan
to inoculate teens before the school
year is out
including manitoba alberta and
newfoundland and labrador
immunizing this age group will be an
important part of achieving greater
community protection
and plans are in development to ensure
first dose of vaccine before
the end of the school year ontario is
doing the same
the biggest province is expecting more
than three million pfizer doses by the
week of may 24th
and more than 7.8 million by the end of
june enough to expand eligible age
groups to include
adolescents the plan would be to
start the vaccinations in in schools
the first dose and then have the second
dose administered before
a return to school date in september one
infectious disease specialist cautions
against inoculating healthy teens
ahead of people at higher risk i think
one of the big things right now is we
still do want to be getting to the
highest risk
people and the highest risk populations
first and thankfully right now
adolescents don't comprise that
population pfizer meantime hopes to get
approval for its vaccine for children
aged 2 to 11 by september
other manufacturers are also testing
children but for now
expanded age groups for pfizer matches
up with canada's deliveries that are
primarily from pfizer
eric sorensen global news toronto
two more canadians have died from
extremely rare blood clots linked to the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine
in new brunswick the chief medical
officer says a person in their 60s
developed symptoms seven days after
receiving the first dose in mid-april
the person went to the hospital and died
two days later of a condition known as
vaccine-induced thrombotic
thrombocytopenia 44 000 doses of the
astrazeneca vaccine have been given in
new brunswick
these are not unexpected outcomes based
on the statistics
but they are tragic and they are sad and
we take them very seriously and we will
continue to evolve
uh as the information becomes clear to
us uh
each passing day in each passing week
and late yesterday alberta reported its
first death linked to the astrazeneca
vaccine
it was a 52 year old woman who was
vaccinated in late april
that province has administered more than
250 000 doses of the astrazeneca vaccine
alberta's chief medical officer of
health says people age 50 to 59
are 350 times more likely to die
from covet 19 than they are to get a
blood clot
linked to the astrazeneca shot alberta's
premier is counting on vaccines and the
latest restrictions he has imposed
to stop the spike in cases and deaths in
that province
jason kenney says he has no tools left
to prevent the worst case scenario
unfolding in the health care system
though his many critics say had he acted
faster and imposed stricter measures
sooner
alberta would be in a much better place
sarah often has the story
this is disgusting a heated
confrontation early wednesday morning as
officials with alberta health services
changed the locks at whistle stop cafe
in rural alberta the business officials
say has flouted public health
restrictions
offering dine in service for months
you're protecting
a government that's not upholding our
rights restriction backlash has been
swift after alberta announced its
toughest measures
since last spring schools are closing
retail is limited and restaurants with
newly expanded patios are takeout only
but businesses considered essentials
such as work in alberta's oil sands
continue to operate this despite
outbreaks at more than a dozen oil and
gas work sites
and hundreds of workers infected that
has some calling for a complete shutdown
while oil prices are finally on the rise
what we're seeing
unfold in the oil sands related
construction camps
is nothing short of a crisis this is
a concern for alberta first and foremost
but it's a concern for the whole country
because many of these people
at the end of their you know their
rotations they fly back to their
provinces
there is already significant pushback to
the measures now in place
more mass rallies are planned for the
weekend and covid fatigue
is a growing reality i'd like to kind of
be able to get back to
seeing my friends and be able to hang
out with
relatives and family and stuff you do
all the best you can you wear your mask
you stay at home you
keep your bubbles small and it's just i
don't know why it's
continuing right it's just really really
upsetting
and frustrating at this point less than
16 hours after restrictions were
announced without the opportunity for
reporter questions
albertans were met with an announcement
that everyone 12 and over will be
eligible to book vaccine appointments by
monday
so why wasn't that announced alongside
restrictions we didn't want
the vaccine announcement to be lost in
that mix by the end of the month alberta
is expected to surpass 50 percent of the
population
vaccinated while a race against both
variants and resistance
continues to rage on if you think this
is going to stop me you got another
thing coming
sarah often global news calgary it is
mental health week and in the heart of
the third wave
talking about mental health and the toll
a pandemic is taking
is more important than ever new polling
from ipsos shows that is happening
as abigail beeman explains experts hope
it means the stigma around mental
health is shrinking samantha lederman
was a new college grad with her first
so-called adult job in event management
the pandemic stripped that away
mental health issues she'd struggled
with for years became worse
it's been way too long since you know i
have been able to go and sit in the cafe
and just have a positive atmosphere or
get away from home or get away from the
environment that could be causing me
anxiety
or causing me to be irritated or
depressed because it's the same four
walls
she's had some virtual support through a
young adult mental health center
stella's place which she credits with
saving her life
but now in the third wave she can't wait
longer for
in-person help i sound very strong but
definitely like i said there becomes a
time where
my my anxiety and my depression is going
to overtake me
according to new ipsos polling letterman
falls into all four of the hardest hit
categories for mental health
women younger people low-income
canadians and people living in ontario
alberta or the atlantic we're kind of
taking the fact that our plans didn't
work out as much
really hard on the whole the number of
canadians facing mental health
challenges continues to climb
half of those survey deemed at high risk
up from 33 percent when tracking began
in 2015
but the survey also found more canadians
are now willing to
talk about it 53 percent with friends
a health care provider or by posting on
social media
i think because so many of us are
impacted by it
it is a lot easier to respond honestly
about like what we're experiencing the
stress and the impact on
our well-being experts are still seeing
increases in appointments and warn the
impacts could be long-lasting
there's generally a tendency to think
that things will get better and it's
usually once we can let our guard down
post having to be in survival mode that
we see a lot of stuff
come up for us as for letterman she's
launched a side business as she looks
for work
it is 150 percent just as important as
talking about a vaccine talking about a
third wave
and she's going to keep talking about
mental health abigail beeman global news
ottawa well we get caught up in which
vaccine we will get here in canada
and when we'll get it but many countries
are nowhere close to where we are
and then there is india it is still
caught in a catastrophe
canada is trying to help we're sending
25 000 vials of the antiviral drug
rem deserver and as many as 350
ventilators from the national emergency
stockpile
it is something but it's not enough
india recorded 382 000 new cases of
covid19 today
and nearly 3 800 more people are known
to have died from the virus
the trajectory is straight up over the
last week india accounted for 46
of all new covid 19 infections around
the world
and 25 percent of all new deaths those
are the official numbers the real toll
including the people dying at home
is likely far higher as redmond shannon
reports hospitals are now taking legal
action to try to force the indian prime
minister
to do more junior doctor rohan agarwal
gets himself ready for another
long shift the 26 year old medic isn't
yet fully qualified
but he's dealing with a crisis unlike
anything any doctor here
has seen what job we are assigned is
what is to be decided by god whom to be
saved whom not to be saved and we are
not made for that we are just humans
amid the staggering infection numbers
the oxygen crisis continues
hospitals are taking the extraordinary
step of going to the
courts to force the government to act
it's extremely unfortunate that
our central government and our state
government cannot find it in themselves
to bury whatever issues they may have
with each other politically or otherwise
and work together just to save people's
lives
i think it just reflects the frustration
quite frankly
that hospitals feel like our last resort
you know
throw the dice go to court and hope that
the courts will help us it's really a
tragic
uh commentary professor vivek de hejia
says prime minister narendra modi's
handling of the crisis
compounds his mistake of declaring
victory over the virus
earlier this year i think the
fundamental problem
is that there is an absence a complete
absence of a national
response of a nationally coordinated
response
another political blow for india
wednesday its foreign minister seen here
in london on monday
is self-isolating after two members of
india's delegation tested positive for
kovit 19 at the g7 foreign minister's
meeting
organizers are hoping infections don't
spread to other
national delegates this week's event
serves partly as a dry run
for next month's g7 leaders summit here
in the u.k redmond shannon global news
london
there has been a breakthrough on the
issue of vaccine patents the u.s
has announced it now supports a proposal
to waive intellectual property
protections
to help boost global vaccine supply our
washington bureau chief jackson proskow
is following this jackson
what prompted the u.s to announce this
now and what does it mean
well donna rich nations like the u.s
have faced pressure to do this for a
while now and so today the biden
administration relented
to the pleas coming from more than 100
other countries
saying it supports a world trade
organization effort to waive these
patent protections on covid vaccines
now the goal here is to allow nations to
produce more vaccine using the formulas
and manufacturing techniques that have
already been developed by pharmaceutical
companies
the us trade representative says the yet
the extraordinary circumstances of the
pandemic
call for such extraordinary measures now
canada has previously been accused of
being too slow to act on this issue
today trade minister mary ing tweeted
that canada actively supports the wto
efforts
to accelerate global vaccine production
and distribution
donna jackson what will this mean in
practical terms to the many poorer
countries who have
vaccinated very few or in some cases
none of their people and can't afford to
build their own vaccine production
facilities
well right now no big difference you
know these wto negotiations could take
weeks or months and even if they are
successful
successful it is questionable as to
whether developing nations could
suddenly start manufacturing these
highly complex vaccines
there are actually plants right here in
the u.s that are even struggling with
this right now
by the time you then get set up to get
the technology
transferred you may be going into the
end of 2022 the beginning of 2023
at which point a lot of people will have
died and of course canadians wondering
if this would help the situation in
canada members of canada's vaccine task
force
say that technology transfer is such a
slow and complicated process
that weighing the patents would not have
improved canada's supply this year
or even next year in short it may help
in the very long term
it does nothing for the immediate goal
of vaccinating as many people around the
world
as quickly as possible donna
okay jackson prosco in washington thanks
it has taken home fitness fans by storm
now peloton is recalling tens of
thousands of its treadmills
find out why coming up
peloton is recalling tens of thousands
of its treadmills less than a month
after denying they were dangerous
they've been linked to the death of one
child and injuries in 29 others
about 125 000 treadmills are being
recalled the
tread model has a touch screen that can
detach and fall about
5400 of them were sold in canada and the
tread plus machine is also being
recalled because children and animals
can be pulled
underneath it peloton says it is not
sold in canada
less than a month ago the company said
consumer warnings about the products
were inaccurate and
misleading there will be no immediate
return to facebook for former u.s
president donald trump
the social media giants oversight board
ruled the company was right to suspend
trump after he expressed support
for rioters at the u.s capitol in
january the oversight board and
independent committee of 20 outside
experts
said trump did create an environment
where a serious risk of violence was
possible
but it also called the indefinite
suspension arbitrary and has given
facebook six months to come up with
clear rules and penalties about
what is and what is not acceptable that
puts the ball back
in mark zuckerberg's court trump called
today's ruling a
total disgrace and said corrupt social
media companies must pay a political
price
trump was also cut off from twitter and
youtube
in january and you may have seen this
interesting photo someone called it
honey
i shrunk the carters president biden and
his wife visited former president carter
and his wife rosalind in
georgia last week and while they look a
little out of proportion or like the
carters live in a dollhouse
photographers think it's a bit of
optical trickery as a result of a strong
flash and a very wide angle lens to
capture them in a tight space
and of course someone on twitter
helpfully fixed it
ditching food bands still ahead the new
school recommendations to keep kids
with allergies safe at school
new guidelines are emerging about
banning nuts and other allergens from
schools and day cares
an international team of allergy experts
reviewed scientific evidence and found
blanket bans on specific foods like
peanuts or dairy
do not reduce allergic reactions instead
the blanket bands result in children
failing to learn how to safely manage
their allergies
researchers are recommending schools
focus on personalized plans
allergy and hygiene education
is again reinforcing the principles of
good training of the teachers
recognition of signs and symptoms and
anaphylaxis action plan for each student
good hand hygiene as well as tabletop
supervision of young children eating
lunches and whatever else is eaten
within the school
schools are also being encouraged to
have their own supply of epipens
the new guidelines have been endorsed by
several organizations including the
canadian society of allergy and clinical
immunology rogue rocket
next tracking where it might land
there is aging wine and then there's
aging wine in space
christy's auction house is selling a
bottle of french wine that spent 14
months on the international
space station as part of a study of food
and agriculture
the bottle is one of 12 that was sent
into orbit and the person with the
winning bid will get a regular bottle
too
just for a comparison the wine might
fetch as much as
1 million dollars well it's a truism to
say that what goes up must come down and
when it comes to old rockets there are
some serious risks
an unmanned chinese rocket is hurtling
its way back to earth right now it is
out of control and no one is certain
where it will land
mike armstrong explains what you need to
know
there was no problem with this launch it
went off last thursday without a hitch
the problem came when the cargo part of
the rocket unhitched from the main
booster
it just floated away there was applause
back at mission control
but concern from others in the space
field
i guess this is a situation which could
have been avoided
paul delaney teaches astronomy at york
university and is a little shocked by
what china's done
that booster rocket is visible from the
ground it's in a temporary
orbit around the globe it's going to
come down the issue
is no one knows where the chances
of hitting a person hitting a house are
small but they should be infinitesimal
you should be able to control the
re-entry
and that is not the case now the rocket
booster is 32 meters long and
5 meters in diameter it's not flying
like an arrow it's
tumbling as it goes basically flipping
over and over
flashing that's the reason it brightens
and dims in the sky
it catches more of the sun's light as it
tumbles
how cool is that it's really negligent
by international standards harvard
astronomer jonathan mcdowell says
china's been somewhat reckless
for a couple of decades the
international community has been careful
when sending up something so big they
make sure there's a planned and
controlled reentry
while the chinese long march 5b rocket
is flown twice
and both times it's meant an
uncontrolled reentry a year ago
another booster rain debris over about
160 kilometers of land in the ivory
coast
so why take the chance i mean it's
cheaper
you know they may have just felt yeah
earth is big
it probably won't hit anyone let's not
bother no the boosters
orbit isn't taking it over canada so it
won't crash here
and mcdowell says most of it'll break up
on reentry so it's not a huge disaster
in the making
it's not good if it's headed towards you
but not he says
evacuate the city bad mike armstrong
global news
well that's a relief that is global
national for this wednesday i'm donna
friesen tonight's your canada is this
bob of seals off seashell bc yes
bob is an actual term i didn't just name
them all bob
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves
bye bye